[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم عربي يهودي هكذا يعرف نفسه ويقول
انه تشرب الثقافه العربيه في سنوات
الطفوله وكان ذلك سببا في عقده نقص تولدت
لديه حين انتقل للاقامه بدوله الاحتلال
المؤرخ اليهودي الذي اقتحم بالروايه
الصهيونيه ودافع عنها اول الامر لينتهي به
المطاف مفندا وناسفا لها وللدعاءاتها بشان
الحقوق اليهوديه في فلسطين ولد عفيش سلايم
عام
1945 لاسره يهوديه عاشت في العراق وهاجرت
الى دوله الاحتلال وهو في سن الخامسه في
رحله يقول انها كانت مؤلمه للغايه وهناك
عانى من تمييزا من سمح لجميع المهاجرين
الافصاح عن جذورهم الاصليه عاد اليهود
المنحدرين من مجتمعات العربيه ولم يكن ذلك
الا بسبب الاستعداد الذي تبنته الصهيونيه
لكل ما هو عربي في الثامنه عشر من عمره
التحقق من الجيش لاداء الخدمه الالزاميه
لتوجه بعدها الى المملكه المتحده ويددرس
التاريخ والعلاقات الدوليه وهم التخصصان
اللذان يقوموا بالتدريسهما الى يومنا هذا
في عدد من الجامعات البريطانيه المرموقه
ينظر الى شلايم باعتباره احد المؤرخين
الاسرائيليين الجدد الذين طرحوا تفسيرات
النقديه لتاريخ اسرائيل والحركه الصهيونيه
وفككت المصطلحات التي رووجد في سياق اثبات
روايه الاحتلال
انه كان مؤمنا باسرائيل كدوله تدفع عن
نفسها خطر اعداء يحيطون بها من كل جانب
ويريدون رميها في البحر لكن الامر اختلف
بعدها حرب 67 حين ضاعفت الدوله الاحتلال
الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها ثلاث مرات وقتها
بدات الحقيقه شاخصه امامه وهي ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بات قوه شرطيه وحشيه لقوه
ينصف المجتمعات العربيه خلال عقبه ما قبل
نشوء دوله الاحتلال
كان في عن تلك المجتمعات استهداف اليهود
بل يرى ان معاهدات الساميه ظاهره اوروبيه
في الاساس انتقلت عدواها الى الدول
العربيه بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه عبر
مواد جرستيرادها وترجمتها لتشكل منطلقا
لمعاداه السهميه في المنطقه مشاهدينا
الكرام الكاتب والمؤرخ ابي شلايم ضيفوا
هذه الحلقه والحلقه التي تليها من
المقابله فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
بروفيشور ابي سليم انا سعيد جدا بوجودك في
المقابله لماذا نصيفطك كل المؤرخ اليهودي
العربي هل مازلت عربيا هل مازلت تحمل
الهويه العربيه ام انتهى الامر بعد رحيل
اليهود العراق ورحيل اسرتك الى اسرائيل
مطلع الخمسينات
يهوديه
وطعامنا وطعام عربي
[موسيقى]
ثم الاسلام
وعراقيون ديانتهم المسيحيه
اذا فهويه الاولى انني عربي يهودي ولكن
حين بلغت الخامسه من العمر انتقلت اسرتي
للعيش في اسرائيل
وهناك حصلت على الهويه الاسرائيليه
واللافت ان وصف عربي اليهودي يعتبر
اشكاليا في اسرائيل بل يقولون انه تعبير
متناقض
فان كنت يهوديا فلا يمكنك ان تكون عربيا
ولو كنت عربيا فلا يمكنك ان تكون يهوديا
ولكنني بالطبع لا اتفق مع ذلك لان العرب
اليهود موجود
ولدوا ونشا في البلدان العربيه كما الامر
معي ومع عائلتي
والغريب انه في اسرائيل يمكن لشخص ان يقول
انا فرنسي اليهودي او روماني يهودي او
اسباني يهودي بل حتى يمكن ان يصف انسان
نفسه انه الماني يهودي على الرغم ما قامت
به المانيا من محرقه ضد اليهود
ولكن ان قلت انا عربي اليهودي تجد الناس
تنثر من ذلك بشكل واضح وذلك لان الصهيونيه
طالما كانت ايدولوجيه تقسيم قامت بتفريق
العرب واليهود
ولكنني ارفض تماما هذا التقسيم المصطنع
الى اسرائيل وكان عمري خمس سنوات عانيت من
عقده نقص لانني كنت عربيا من العراق
الانسان الذي يعيش على
الحواف والهوامش وتقاطع في حياته الهويات
يعيش حياه صعبه هل كان امرا ثقيلا على
ابشليم
هذه الحياه المتقاطعه بين العربيه من
ناحيه واليهوديه من ناحيه كدينه
والاسرائيليه هل كان امرا ثقيلا عليك طوال
مسيرتك في الحياه انت اليوم في منتصف
السبعينات
من بلد عربي وكان العالم العربي هو العدو
وكذلك لانه اسرائيل صنعت من قبل اليهود
الاوروبيين واليهود الاشكناز والذين طالما
نظروا تجاه اليهود العرب
لم يكن لي احد يوما انك اقل قدرا ومكانه
منا ولكن الامر كان محسوسا بوضوح
خفيا ولكنه كان واضح
فكانت القناعه ان كل شيء عربي كان اقل
قدرا مما عند اسرائيل
من كتابه مذكراته سنوات الاولى وحتى بلغت
الثاني عشر من العمر
والمذكرات بعنوان
العوالم الثلاثه مذكرات عربي يهودي
والعوالم الثلاثه هي بغداد حتى سن الخامسه
ثم اسرائيل حتى سن الخامسه عشر ثم المدرسه
في لندن من سن الخامسه عشر حتى سن الثامن
عشر
وهذا الكتاب ليؤرخ لعائلته والمحور الاساس
هو انتقاله اسرته من العالم العربي الى
اسرائيل
ساتحدث عن هذه المذكرات بالتفصيل
استوقفت لعده نقاط جدتك بماذا تصرف العراق
يقولون
جنه مع الله
وانت
تقول ايضا انك كاننا نحضرنا حينما جئنا من
العراق ان حدرنا من الاعلى الى الاسفل هل
هذا التوصيف دقيق يعني انتم كيف تنظرون
لحياتكم كي يهود عراقيين كعرب مقارنه بما
عشتوه في اسرائيل
بوصف ماي جراند
في اسرائيل ولم تكونا تتحدثان الى العربيه
حيث لم تتعلمها
العبريهما الشبكه
[موسيقى]
انت انت
كنتم يهودا في بلد عربي ومسلم ثم ذهبتم
الى كونكم يهود في بلدي يهودي فلماذا تصبح
هذه عذاب يعني والدك تقول في مذكراتك
والدك كان يقول 2,000 سنه كان اليهود
يسعون لاقامه الدوله حظي انا انهم يسوون
دوله في حياتي ههه يعني كان كانت هناك
حاله استياء فاقصد لماذا هذا الاشتياق ان
تكون يهودي في دوله يهوديه جديده
فقط عليكم كيهود عرب ام بشكل عام
القديس
كورد عندي احد واقربائي اسمه اسحاق
وهو بدوره انتقل من العراق الى اسرائيل
كلها باللغه العربيه
احدها بعنوان الخروج من العراق
[موسيقى]
في العراق
مواجهه الروايات التي يعني عملت اسرائيل
على على ان تسود في العالم سنتحدث عن كل
هذه التفاصيل كيف نشات اسرائيل حسب روايه
المريخين
هذه النخبه في نهايه الثمانينات اريد ان
اتذكر معك العراق
تتحدث عن شيء مهم تقول لم يكن هناك ماساه
تتعلق باليهود في العالم العربي او
الاسلامى الاسلامي كان هناك ماساه تتعلق
باليهود في اوروبا
كيف كانت حياه اليهود في العراق حياتكم
انتم كالاسره عراقيه في تلك الفتره في
نهايه الاربعين قبل الانتقال الى الدوله
المصنوعه الجديده
العراق
تاريخ طويل من العيش المشترك
بين المسلمين واليهود
فاليهود لم يعتبروا يوما قادمين جددا او
مهاجرين
وبالتاكيد لم يكونوا متطفلين في العراق
منذ
2500 عام
وقبل ظهور الاسلام بكثير
كما كانت في العراق
بينما في اوروبا كان اليهود هم انفسهم من
يمثل الاخر
الاخر في العرب في العالم العربي
والاسلامي لم يكن الاخر
ولكن يحسب لها بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
مدنيه وثقافيه
لذلك
فان فلسفه الامبراطوريه العثمانيه كانت
قائمه على مبدا التعدديه والتعايش بين
المنتمين لديانات المختلفه
بينما فلسفه الامبراطوريه البريطانيه في
فلسطين العثمانيه
عزيز اثيوديد ففي عهد العثمانيين كان يسعك
ان تكون مواطن اليهوديه او مسيحيا في ظل
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه لماذا تم التركيز
على هذه الحاله معادلات الحاله اليهوديه
العربيه فيما الماساه كانت في اوروبا
تتعلق بالمساله اليهوديه وانا ما نتج عنها
بالاخير الهولوكوست والنازيه الاعمال
النازيه والمحارق لماذا تم التركيز على
محاوله خلق عداء يهودي عربي اسلامي من اجل
التبرير لقيام دوله جديده
انت ازيك
تعتبر ظاهره اوروبيه
ولا تجد لها موضع قدم في العالم العربي
في فتره ما بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى
وفي الفتره ما بين الحرب بين العالمين
وظهرت فجاه مواد دعائيه
اوغندا نازيه في العراق
ما ادى الى ظهور حاله الساميه
لم تكن ظاهره طبيعيه المنشا في العالم
العربي
بل تم استيرادها من اوروبا حيث لم يكن في
العالم العربي
فكان لزاما ترجمه مواد اوروبيه فيها تحريض
على معاه الساميه الى اللغه العربيه
الروايه الرسميه الصهيونيه تؤكد ان معاه
الساميه كانت متاصله في العالم العربي
وسببها وربما تجدر الاشاره الى حاله فريده
في التاريخ العراقي تستغل كدليل من قبل
الصهاينه
بالفرهود وهي ابتداءات على اليهود في
العراق
عام
بعد ثوره رشيد علي الكيلاني الذي كان
مناهضا للامبرياليه
لكنه لم يكن معاد لساميه
فارسل البريطانيون قوات طارد فيه الكيلاني
واتباعه فحصل فراغ في السلطه
وخلال هذه الفتره وقعت الاعتداءات على
اليهود
الروايه الصهيونيه تؤكد ان هذه الحادثه
تمثل شعورا اصيلا بكره اليهود
ومعادات الساميه بينما في الحقيقه لم تكن
هذه الاعتداءات الا حاله فرديه وظاهره
معزوله
البدايه وهي فقره تتعلق ببداياتك وحياتك
كنتم تجار كان اليهود تجار في العراق وفي
اليمن وفي اكثر من مكان كان هناك فن كان
فنانين كويتيين وعراقيين يهود اين ذهب
الارث العربي لليهود العرب الذين هاجروا
للدوله المصنعه الجديده
اين ذهب هذا الارث موسيقاكم تراكم
ارزقكم كاملا
في عام 1948
كان هناك
750 الف لاجئين فلسطينيه
فانما يقارب
850 الف يهوديا عربي
هؤلاء جميعا لم يكونوا لاجئين ولم يتعرضوا
للنفي او التهجير
كانوا من مناطق مختلفه من العالم العربي
كالمغرب
وانتهى بهم المطاف في اسرائيل
وللاسف الشديد لم يبقى شيء يذكر من ارثهما
الثقافيه او الحضري او من موسيقىهم همم
وكان بينهم الكتاب والروائيون الذين لم
يكونوا يكتبون الا باللغه العربيه
وبعضهم استمر يكتب بالعربيه مثل ميرنا
قايش بينما قضى اخرون سنوات حتى تعلموا
الكتابه بالعبريه مثل صديقي سامي ميخائيل
والذي كان عضوا في الحزب الشيوعي في بغداد
ثقافه الاسرائيليه بعد الاستقلال كانت
ثقافه اوروبيه الطابعه
كبير ومعرفتها بالعالم كانت من منطلق
القراءه الاوروبيه
بل ان النخب الاسرائيليه لم ترددها جزءا
من الشرق الاوسط
كانوا يرون اسرائيل جزءا مما يسمى العالم
الحر وجزء من الغرب
واشتهر عن
قوله
خطا جغرافي
اسرائيل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
بينما قيمنا وثقافتنا
تجعلنا جزءا من اوروبا
تجاه اليهود ذوي الاصول العربيه
وبما ان هؤلاء القادمين الجدد ارادوا
اكتسابه هويه صهيونيه اسرائيليه جديده
فقد اثر الابتعاد عن تراثهم الحقيقي
للتراث العربي في اسرائيل
والناس تعبر عن ارثها العربي بقدر من
الفخر
الوجود علم فلسطين وعلم الاردن لماذا
لماذا تضع هذا العلم على يعني سترته
جدا بتاريخ الاردن
وليا اصدقاؤه كثر من هنالك
هو بلد المفضل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط بل
ربما في العالم اجمع
ولكنني ايضا عالم في تاريخ الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي ولا شك ان ضحايا هذا الصراع
وضحايا الصهيونيه هما الفلسطينيون لذا
فتعاطى فيه هو مع الشعب الفلسطيني
والجلسه البسيطه هنا في اكسفورد اريد ان
اتحدث معك عن قضايا كثيره وكبيره كيف
انتقل هذا العربي اليهودي الى اسرائيل
ويتحقق الجيش ااه مجندان ثم اصبح قوميا
اسرائيليا ثم ارتد عن ذلك قصص كثيره انا
سعيد جدا مره اخرى بوجودك معي تفضل
[موسيقى]
حريه دينيه مقفوله ومكانه في اعلى هرم
المجتمع كان هذا حال الطوائف اليهوديه في
معظم البلدان العربيه قبل موجات الخروج
الى دولته من الوليد التي انشاتها الحركه
الصهيونيه بعد سلسله من الماسي والجرائم
بحق فلسطين واهلها في العراق كان المجتمع
اليهودي احد اكبر المجتمعات اليهوديه
العربيه واعراقها حيث قدرت اعداد افراده
قبل التهجير بحوالي 150,000 وتشيل
احصائيات الى ان يهود بغداد شكل يوما ما
ثلث سكان المدينه وكان بعضهم من اغنى
اغنياء العالم اما في مصر فقد شكل اليهود
مكونه سياسيا واجتماعيا واقتصاديا مهما
قدر قبل النكبه ب 80,000 شخص برز كثير
منهم في التجاره والفنون والثقافه وسجل
حضوره ضمن الصفوف الاولى في هذه المجالات
جميعا وجاء خروجهم على مراحل ثلاث الاولى
والثانيه بين عامي 48 و54 بينما كان
الرحيل الاكبر عام 56 بالتزاملي مع
العدوان الثلاثيه على مصر في اليمن تركز
اليهود في عدن ومدن اخرى
وقدرت مصادر اعدادهم قبل النكبه بسبعه
الاف شخص عمل معظمه في انحراف اليدويه
بينما اشتغل قليل منهم في الرعي والزراعه
اما دول المغرب العربي فسجل اليهود حضور
فاعلا وخصوصا في المغرب الذي حضروا فيه
بواقع مميز للدعايه شو معظم الوقت مع
المغاربه المسلمين ومنع المغرب تسليمهم
للنازيين باعتبارهم مواطنين مغاربه كما
مكنهم احترافه معظمهم مجال المال والاعمال
من العيش في رغد في ظل حمايه الحكام
المغاربه المتعاقبين وهو واقف ما زال
مستمرا الى اليوم
منطقه الخليج سجلت هي الاخرى حضورا لبعض
التجمعات اليهوديه وامتهن معظم افرادها
الرايه والتجاره والزراعه والحرف اليدويه
كما برز عدد منهم في الفنون والثقافه
بروفيسور اكرر سعادتي بوجودك معي في
هذه الحلقات من المقابله وهي في غايه
الاهميه تتحدث عن مرحله دقيقه قيام
اسرائيل انتقال اليهود العرب
باعتقادكم ما الذي ساهم بانتقال اليهود من
البلدان العربيه لاسرائيل كيف كيف تمت هذه
العمليه انت تذكر في مذكراتك انها ليست
عمليه ايدولوجيه هي عمليه سياسيه عمليه
تهجير تكاد تكون قصريه لليهود العرب
ايراني
العراقي من اقدم واميز المجتمعات اليهوديه
في العالم المسلم
وكان في العراق في عام 1950
130 الف يهودي
وبعد عامين فقط انتهى الامر بهجره
120,000 منهم الى اسرائيل
لذا فالمجتمع اليهودي باسره تم اختلاعه من
الجذور اذ لم يبقى منه في العراق سوى
10,000
فالعمليه باسرها كانت بالطبع عمليه في
غايه الصعوبه
فقد كان الامر كاقتلاع شجره عتيقه من
جذورها
والسؤال ينبغي ان يكون
لماذا تمت هذه الهجره الجماعيه
والجواب ببساطه
ان معظم اليهود العراقيين
كانوا
يعرفون انفسهم بانهم عراقيون
وكان العراق بالنسبه لهم
وطنايا ايجابيا
ضمن المجتمع العراقي
بل يمكننا القول بان يهود العراق كانوا
اكثر اندماجا من اي مجتمع يهودي اخر في اي
بلد عربي
وساهموا في بناء الامه العراقيه في كافه
مستوياتها
الفكريه
والاقتصاديه والماليه
همم في كل المستويات ومن ضمنها الخدمه
المدنيه
كانت هناك حركه صهيونيه في العراق ولكنها
لم تحظى الا بعضويه اعداد قليله
فالمجتمع اليهودي في مجمله لم يكن صهيونيا
فصهيونيه كانت ظاهره الاوروبيه
وطالما تحدثت والدته عن اصدقائنا المسلمين
الرائعين
وحين سالتها يوما هل كان لدينا اصدقاء من
الصهاينه
فاجابتني بكثير من الاستغراب لا
زيه وكانت تقول الصهيونيه شيء اوروبي
الصهيونيه شيء يرتبط بالاشكناز وهو امر لا
يتعلق بنباتات
لذا فاللهجره الجماعيه عمليه في غايه
التعقيد
وحدثت نتيجه اسباب كثيره واحد واهم تلك
الاسباب كان انتشار القوميه العربيه
والشعور المتنامي بالعداء نحو اليهود في
العراق بعد الحرب العربيه الاسرائيليه عام
التي شارك فيها الجيش العراقي بالقتال في
فلسطين وما نتج عن شعور بالتعاطف مع
الفلسطينيين بسبب قيام اسرائيل بتردهم
والاستماع على اراضيهم
وسبب اخر لهذه الهجره الجماعيه هو الضغط
الذي مارسته لحركه الصهيونيه على يهود
العراق كي يتركوا وطنهم وينتقل الى
اسرائيل
بل اذهب لما هو ابعد واقول ان الصهيونيه
كانت ظاهره في غايه القسوه وقامت بعده
مراحل اولها التطير العراقي لفلسطين حيث
اصبح 43 مليون فلسطين لاجئا بين ليله
وضحاها بينما كانت المرحله الثانيه
الاتيان باكبر عدد من اليهود من اي مكان
في العالم كي يحلوا محل الفلسطينيين الذين
طردوا وماتوا لاجئين
فصهيونيه كانت عاملا مهما في انهاء وجود
هذا المجتمع اليهودي العراقي
السؤال بروفيسير هل كانت الحركه الصهيونيه
فاعله في البلد لان العربيه التي تتواجد
بها جاليا يهوديه مثل العراق المغرب غيره
فاعله بشكل كبير ثم هل من تعاون حكومي
رسمي عربي من قبل الانظمه
ادى مجتمعا الى عمليه التجير القسري
لليهود العرب الى اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
مهمه ضمن الاقتصاد العراقي
حيث كان اليهود سيافه وتجار واصحاب اموال
وفي مارس
سنه الحكومه العراقيه قانون نص على ان من
حقه يهودي يريد الهجره من العراق ان يفعل
ذلك من خلال التسجيل في سجل مفتوح لمده
سنه كامله
ويسمح لهم بعده بالهجره من العراق
تنازل عن كافه حقوقهم كمواطنين عراقيين
واسقاط جنسيتهم العراقيه
وقد صارت شائعه بان اتفاقا سريا كان قد
ابري ما بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه وحكومه
نور السعيد
بان يترك اليهود يهاجرون ولكن من دون ان
ياخذوا معهم شيئا من اموالهم او ممتلكاتهم
اذ قال الطرف العراقي انه لو سمحت لليهود
العراقيين بالهجره واخذ كافه ثرواته معهم
فان ذلك سيؤدي بالاقتصاد العراقي الى
الانهيار
ولكنني بحثت في هذه المساله تحديدا ولم
احثر على اي دليل عليها او على وجود اتفاق
كهذا
ولكن الذي يمكنني قوله هو ان اسرائيل بعد
حرب عام
1948 كانت تلهث وراء الطاقه البشريه
حيث لم يكن هناك سوا 600 الف يهوديا بعد
انتهاء الحرب
فباتت الاولويه
هي عاليه او الهجره قريش فقامت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بكل ما تستطيعه كي تستقدم
اليهود العرب الى اسرائيل
لابد من احضار اليهود ليحل محلهم
ليس الامر بتلك البساطه
ذلك كانت خطه تنفيذيه
مصممه للجيش الاسرائيلي لاجل الاستيلاء
على بعض الاراضي والتي لم تنص عليها خطط
الفصل التي اصدرتها الامم المتحده
كانت عباره عن مشروع استهلاء على اراضي
كانت مقره دوليا للدوله الفلسطينيه
وتضمن ذلك تردد سكان العرب من تلك الاراضي
و بالطبع من نتائجه خطه الثالث القيام
باعمال تطهير عراقي في بعض المناطق ولكن
ليس لهذا علاقه مباشره بما جاء بعد ذلك من
هجره جماعيه اليهود من العراق
وعدد اخر من البلدان العربيه والذي جاء في
وقت لاحق الجانب التاريخي والسياسي ساتحدث
عنه في الحلقه الثانيه اريد الان ان اكمل
بتجربتك الشخصيه
حينما انتقلتم لاسرائيل تقول اننا عانينك
يا عرب حتى انك كنت تخجل من حديث والدك
معك بالعربيه اريد ان اتحدث عن سنوات
الدراسه الاولى سنوات التحول من العربيه
الى العبريه
والانتقال الى كونك مواطن اسرائيلي في هذه
الدوله الجديده ما طبيعه المعانات الشخصيه
والاسريه في سنواتك الاولى في سنوات
الدراسه والتعليم الاولى
نور
بغداد
الى اسرائيل كان انتقالا مؤلم للغايه
كانت والدتي تحمل جواز سفر بريطانيا حيث
كان والدها مترجما لدى القوات البريطانيه
في العراق
ام والدي فكان راقيا ولم يكن يريد ترك
العراق واراد البقع غير ان الاوضاع باتت
خطره فاضطر بعدها ان يغادر بشكل غير
قانوني بمساعده مهربين من الكرد عبر
الحدود الى ايران ثم الى العاصمه طهران
وبعدها ينضم الينا في اسرائيل
كنت وقتها في الخامسه من العمر كانت
والدتي في نهايه العشرينيات بينما كان
والدي يبلغ 50 عاما
والحقيقه انه لم يتعافى من صدمه هذا
الانتقال اذا بقي عاطلا على العمل بعد ان
فقد معظم ثروته وكان في حاله من الحزن
الشديد في اسرائيل ولم يتاقلم مع الحياه
الجديده
اما انا واختي فقد كنا صغارا وذهبنا الى
المدرسه وتعلمنا العبريه وكنا نتحدث مع
بعضنا بالعبريه
مع اصدقائي في الطرقات اثناء فصل الصيف
حيث كنا نرتدي الشورت ونلبس الصندل في
اقدامنا فجاء والدي وهو بكامل اناقته
يرتدي بدله وقميص ابيض
وحدثني باللغه العربيه امام اصدقائي
شعرت حينها بالحرج الشديد لانه كان يحدثني
بالعربيه
فقد كانت العربيه تعتبر لغه قبيحه في
اسرائيل باللغه البدائيه فشعرت بالخجل
وجبته اجابات مختصبه للغايه وكنت اريد ان
اقول له ابي لا باس من التحدث بالعربيه في
المنزل
ان تحدثني بالعبريه حين اكون مع اصدقائي
ولكنني لم اقول له شيئا لا حينها ولا بعد
ذلك
ومثلت هذه الذكرى مقدار الصعوبه البالغه
في التواصل بيني وبين والدي بعد انتقالنا
الى اسرائيل
في السادسه عشره واقل من ذلك في خدمه
التجنيد
في عام 19646
لانني كنت قد تاتلكت خلال فتره مواظبه في
المدرسه
واذكر جيدا حين كنت جنديا في مراسم
التدشين وكان الوقت قريبا من فتره المغيب
وكنا نضل على تلال الاردن
وانشدنا بكل فخر بالدم والنار سقطت يهودا
وبالدم والنار ستنهضي يهود ثانيه
وادينا جميعا قسم الولاه لدوله اسرائيل ثم
اطلقت لعيره الناريه التي اضاعت السماء
ومنطلق كوني اكاديميا هناك الكثير من
الدراسات الاكاديميه التي تناولت موضوع
القوميه ودوافعه
ولكنني اقول وبكل صدق
انني شعرت يومها بالمشاعر القوميه بكل
كيانه
فقد كنت مؤمنا باننا كنا بلدنا طيبا محبا
للسلام
عربيه تريد اقتناصنا وتدميرنا والقائنا
نحن اليهود في البحر
عن انفسنا وقيامنا ذلك
ولكن بعد مرور عام واحد في حرب 67
كنت طالبا في السنه الاولى
ادرس التاريخ بجامعه كامبردج وكنت غايه في
الوطنيه
وتوجهت الى السفاره الاسرائيليه في لندن
واخبرتهم بانني اريد العوده للمشاركه في
الحرب التي كان من الواضح انها قادمه
فاخذوا معلومات الشخصيه وقالوا لي لو
احتجناك سنتواصل معك ولم اسمع منهم بعدها
بيكوز
وتغير مشاعري حياه لاسرائيل فقد بدا بعد
عام 67
لانني رايت جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي خلال
فتره خدمه العسكريه جيشا يقوم بما وصف
نفسه به تماما جيشا نظاميا يواجه جيوش
عربيه النظاميه
وكان ذلك الجيش يمثل قوه دفاعيه بحته
ولكن بعد عام 67 وبعد ان ضاعفت اسرائيل من
الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها ثلاث مرات بعد
ان تمت هضبه الجولان والضفه الغربيه
باتت اسرائيل قوه استعماريه الوحشيه
وجيشها الذي تدرب كجيش النظامي لكي يحارب
جيوش النظاميه مات جيش الاحتلال في فتره
خدمته لم نرى او نتعامل مع مدنيين عرب منذ
ذلك الوقت وحتى يومنا هذا باتت مهمه الجيش
حمايه امن الاحتلال بروفيسور انت ترى انه
عام 67 مفصلي في موقفك يعني انت تؤمن
باسرائيل ما قبل 67 وما بعد 67 تحولت الى
مشروع استيطان واستعماري
زميلك من نخبه المؤرخين الجدد يرى العكس
ان اسرائيل من اللحظه الاولى كانت مشروع
استعماريا كولونيلين فبالتالي لماذا ما
زلت مسرا على ان 67 هو المفصلي رغم كل
الدلائل التي تؤكد ان هذا المشروع يعني من
اللحظه الاولى له هو كذلك مشروع استعمال
وكنت ممتحنه في مقابله احتمال الرساله
فهو اصغر سنا مني ولكنني يعترف انني تعلمت
الكثير منه
ولا شكا بانك كافه مبادئ التاريخ الجديد
موجوده في كتابه بشكل او باخر
من الناحيه السياسيه
لطالما كان ايلان بابي اكثر راديكاليه مني
بكثير حيل الحركه الصهيونيه فهو يؤمن بان
الصهيونيه مشروع استعماري من يومها الاول
وبان صهيونيه كانت الحليفه الاصغر
البريطاني العظمى وهذا ما جعل منها مشروعا
استعمالا استطانيا من لحظه البدايه ولم
يتغير شيء منذ ذلك
يعتقد ان عمل 48 كان مرحله من مراحل تحقيق
المشروع الصهيوني بينما شكل عام 67 مرحله
اخرى لذلك المشروع حين تمت اسرائيل
سيطرتها على فلسطين
ولذلك فهو مؤمن بان اسرائيل كانت فاقده
للشرعيه ضمن حدود عام 48 كما انها
بالتاكيد تفتقد للشرعيه بشكلها
يعني 67
لا شك ان قناعتي كانت مختلفه فقد كنت ارى
ان تاسيس دوله اسرائيل وكبه ظلم عظيم
ارتكب بحق الفلسطينيين
ولكنني اشرت الى انه بعد انتهاء الحرب في
عام 48
وقعت اسرائيل اتفاقيه لوقف اطلاق النار مع
كافه جيرانها وبذلك فالخطوط التي رسمت
بموجب تلك الاتفاقيه في عام 49 هي الخطوط
الوحيده التي تمتعت بها اسرائيل
وكنت اعتبرها خطوطا شرعيه وقانونيه وبذلك
اعتبروا اسرائيل ما قبل 67 وضمن حدودها
المذكوره دوله شرعيه
واذكروا ان زوجتي كانت تسخر مني وتختصر
رحله الاكاديميه البحثيه عبر 50 سنه
بالقول اسرائيل ما قبل 67 جيدا واسرائيل
ما بعد 67 سيئه ولكن رايي في هذا الصدد لم
تكن بتلك البساطه وهي اراء تعرضت للتغيير
في ضوء موقف الانبابي اصبحت الان انظر الى
تاريخ اسرائيل منذ بدايته وبنت مخترعا بان
المشروع هو بالاساس مشروع استطلاني
كنت في السابق افرق بين اسرائيل الاصل
وبين اسرائيل التي تضم اراضي محتله واقول
بشرعيه اسرائيل ولكنني اعقب بالقوم ان
المستوطنات التي اقامتها اسرائيل في الضفه
الغربيه هي التي تمثل المشروع الصهيونيه
الاستيطاني خارج حدود الخط الاخضر اليوم
اصبحت اجد من الصعوبه ان ارى اسرائيل
مشروع يبتسم بالشرعيه لان دوله اسرائيل
باتت في حقيقتها دوله تمارس النظام الفصل
العنصريه
للاحتلال
ساخصص الحلقه الثانيه لكافه الاسئله
التاريخيه وطبيعه دور ومهامه المؤرخين
الجدد على راسهم ابي شليم كيف نشات هذه
الدوله دور بريطانيا الدور الرسم العربي
وما الى ذلك اريد ان انا افكر بفلسطين
انها ما زالت هي ارض عربيه تعود لاصحابها
طال الزمان ام قصر اريد ان اتسائل من
زاويه اخرى من زاويه يهوديه
هل تنظر لاسرائيل اليوم بعد 70 سنه على
انها الجنه المنتظره لليهود هي البلاد
التي ستكون مستقر اليهود العالم
ام ان هذا الامر ما زال مزعزا
وغير امن بالنسبه لاصحاب هذا المشروع
الوسكريته اسرائيل بانها نشات لغرض توفير
ملاذ امن لليهود العالم اجمع
وهذه شكلت المفرده الاخلاقيه الرئيسي
لاقامه دوله اليهوديه
حيث قدمت ان اليهود يمثلون اقليه في
اوروبا
انتهى في عشيه حرب 67
ان كانت هناك دوله يهوديه مستقله
تتمتعوا بمقومات النجاح
ان نقول انجزنا المهمه فقد نجحت لحركه
الصهيونيه في اقامه ملاذ امن لليهود وان
اليهود العالم مرحب بهم للقدوم والعيش هنا
حيث انها الملاذ الوحيد لهم ولكن اسرائيل
بقيت تمارس العنف وتستخدم القوه وبذلك هي
مسؤوله عن سلسله من الحروب بينها وبين
الجيوش العربيه ومنذ عام
1967 كانت كافه المواجهات والحروب بسبب
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لاعراض فلسطينيه
وبذلك في اسرائيل قامت بشعال الصراع
واثائه ولا سيما ان الفرصه كانت متاحه
لاسرائيل ان تبرم اتفاقيه سلام مع الملك
حسين ملك الاردن مقابل اعاده الضفه
الغربيه والقدس الشرقيه للولايات الاردنيه
وقد عرض الملك حسين على اسرائيل سلاما
شاملا مقابل الانسحاب شامل ولكن عرضه قوبل
برفض الاسرائيلي
منذ عام
1967 كان العرض امام اسرائيل هو الارض
مقابل السلام
وبقيه اسرائيل ترفض ذلك المره تلو المره
ولذلك استمر الصراع لذا لم تعد اسرائيل
مكانا امنا لليهود كما لم تعد ملاذا امنا
بل لم تعد مكان جذابا لليهود الليبراليين
يضاف الى ذلك تحول مشاعر اليهود حول
العالم اذا اسرائيل
وهو امر ملفت للغايه ولا سيما في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
ففي امريكا هناك منظمه اسسها اليهود
الليبراليون تسمى
من اليهود الليبراليين الذين يوجهون
لاسرائيل
ولسياساتها القائمه على نظام الابر تايد
نقد اللاذعا
ويعلنون صراحه ان اسرائيل لا تمثلهم
ويدعمون فكره حل الدولتين
ورغم ان منظمه ايباد والتي اعتادت ان تمثل
المجتمع اليهودي في امريكا
لم تعد تمثلوا سوى حوالي 30 في المئه من
اليهود الامريكيين
بينما باتت جي ستريت تمثل قرابه 70 في
المائه المؤرخ والاكاديميه البارزه في
شليم ضيف المقابله في جزءها الاول شكرا
جزيلا لكم في الجزء الثاني سنبحث معك كثير
من القضايا حول حول هذا التاريخ الذي
قراتموه انت وزملائك من جديد وقدمتم تصورا
جديدا مخالفه للروايه الصهيونيه حول نشاه
اسرائيل وكيف كانت هذه النشر شكرا جزيلا
لك شكرا منصور لكم
في الحلقه القادمه دمتم بخير السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]